dwight i want you to be in charge of the
press conference
yes you're entering the no spin zone
we're having a press conference
no pam the press are just gonna find out
by themselves
not here's the thing when a company
screws up
best thing to do is call a press
conference alert the media
and then you control the story wait for
them to find out
and the story controls you that's what
happened to oj
i have invited barbara allen one of our
oldest clients to come in here
and meet with me for a personal apology
the press wants a story i will give them
a story
oh did the press ask for a story thank
you for meeting here
sure what's up okay i need you to get
this word for word
it's a tape recorder so it will
gazebo more like gazoinx bow she may be
a former beauty queen but today she's
the king
of destroying history okay could you
just maybe talk normally
okay fine because winx bow jessica wicks
is throwing a birthday party for her
husband nick newport senior
at the turnbull mansion tonight here is
your headline
screen area paper company dunder
mifflin apologizes to valued
client some companies
still know how business is done
you know if we catch him then we avoid a
scandal
because we flip the headline and it's
not community garden infested with pot
it's brave public servants rid
neighborhood of drugs
earn praise from mayor comma everyone
five
four three there is no way
i will resign it wouldn't be fair
not to the good workers i work with not
to
my clients and especially not to me
let's not forget who this whole
resigning business
is about anyway if i could leave you
with one thought remember it wasn't me
they are trying to make me an escape
coat
if i am fired i swear to god that every
single piece of copier paper in this
town
is going to have the f-word on it
the f word you have one day
one day for what that's they always give
an ultimatum
okay good cut cut
that was your best apology video ever
thought so too
headline idea it's the end of the world
as they know it but pawnee feels fine
it's a little long okay zorp schmorp
doomsday protection falls flat as
citizens spend pleasant evening
enjoying one of pawnee's finest parks
somehow longer
right okay let's go with the first one
michael scott
yes do you want to make a comment on the
rumors
um i have done some very bad things
things of which i am not proud i would
like to
publicly apologize to
the coach and the players and i vow
to never listen to
my bodily instincts ever again
i'm talking about the saber printers
that catch on fire oh okay
i was talking about uh what it what
what's going on
harvest festival more like harvest
bestival the parks department has
planted the seeds and now they're
harvesting their rewards
great you done they'll put the fun in
funnel cake
okay now i'm done there is nothing wrong
nor will there ever be wrong
with any saber printers case closed
michael scott as seen on tv i saw you on
the news and i want to pinch your tiny
wiener
it's packer oh pacman i thought you were
a girl
apparently there are allegations that
saber printers can cause
a fire so they asked me to give a
statement to the press
i'm like what all right so i do it
it's on tv last night and it's in the
paper
today and it's online and then i call
froggy 98.7 their request line
i talked to the host about it on the air
it's like come on
people enough everybody we are at
defcom5
i am officially the second most watched
clip of the day on the wbre news site
what's number one oh that teacher who
was wrongfully accused of being a
pedophile now
we cannot let the pedophile win again i
would like you all to go to the website
and watch my clip 11 times so instead of
working yes
okay yes
did you see this report that the zoo got
a baby otter
it's on the same site oh it's kissing
it's mommy
oh you have to see this is like the
cutest thing ever
[Laughter]
really a baby otter okay um
count me in as who cares it's not even
that
interesting a baby otter they can't even
stand up
he's trying to stand up
there he goes the headline i would have
gone with
is no strike bowling bowler struck
by nope striking bow
did you get all that everything
you